science can be pretty darn cute we at
nature as suckers for a bit of cuteness
as long as there's a bit of science in
there - so here goes with the top ten
cute animals of science 2014 in at
number 10 these little square eyed
marmosets researchers showed that these
little guys can learn by watching how-to
videos they installed a tree TV and
played a vid of some other marmosets
extracting a treat from a box
most of those who watched it learn to do
it themselves next step box sets of
David Attenborough in at number 9
magneto dogs a team based in the czech
republic found that dogs line up their
bodies with the Earth's magnetic field
when they pee from spaniels to
schnauzers they all do it his extra
sense hasn't been seen before in dogs
and it won the researchers an ignoble
prize this year prizes for science that
makes you laugh and then think this
Pomeranians behavior however is
unexplained by research moving up the
list and down to the deep sea this is a
Dumbo octopus you can see why even its
name is cute look at what its little
legs are doing that's the science bit
actually this body posture with the arms
spiraled like this has never been seen
in a Dumbo octopus before the vid was
filmed during an expedition in the Gulf
of Mexico at number 7 not one but 14 new
species of this tiny little critter Nick
Rick sillas but that's not all they
dance if you call flicking your legs
around dancing the male's use this
attractive move to get the girls the
streams they live near are too loud for
calls so they show a bit of leg instead
the new species doubles the number of
dancing frogs known to science yes 'burn
busy what do you want
and all lizards like this guy are
excellent hiders ok maybe this one isn't
but they often stow away on ships in
plants or other cargo and spread from
one island to another where they live in
the Caribbean ecologists found this year
that human boat traffic has redone the
patterns that evolution has spent
thousands of years establishing
economics above geography is affecting
the spread of these little lizards
number five okay okay they're not
animals but they are so all cute and on
mass they're very smart they're building
these pictures totally on their own
having been given a plan each robot the
size of a penny follows the next to
carry out the plan their swarm behavior
is based on biological principles
allowing each bot to be stupid but the
product to be stylish because who
doesn't want to starfish built out of
robots considering a new hairstyle for
the new year look no further than to pay
monkeys for inspiration this one this
one this one maybe this style this
mustache
you should five new species of these
cuties were identified this year
previously wrongly identified as
subspecies they live in the forests of
Brazil Bolivia and Peru where they are
experts in camouflage and other forest
residents do not appreciate their
fashion-forward hairdos cute or scary
you decide this isn't a still from
monsters Inc it's an extreme close-up of
the eyes of a jumping spider in at
number three the whole thing looks like
this see cute the eyes won third place
in the nokia small world photo
competition for photographer Noah Fram
Schwartz back in October the spider eyes
are at 20 times magnification okay get
ready for cute overload as we move into
the final turn you I'm so excited in
second place
a team who dressed up this robot as a
baby penguin the robot on its own scared
these emperor penguins but after its
fluffy makeover they were fine with it
some of them even tried to talk to it
some of these paintings are tacked and
the robot is carrying a reader for the
tags the penguin robot disguise helps
monitor the Penguins without stressing
them out the cutest little koala that
ever tree hugs
Carla's hug trees we all know that but
why this year scientists suggested they
do it to keep cool as you can see from
these thermal images the Koala positions
itself on the coolest part of the tree
and then chills out as the temperature
climbs koalas really go for it with the
hugging giving the cooling tree a great
big squeeze and that rounds up our top
10 cutest science stories of the year
click on each cute box for more now
who's got that warm fuzzy feeling